as the Baby Boomers you know age out
like you age out of life there will be
there will be you know people that will
be going into the age bracket where
they're paying more attention to news
and paying more attention to uh you know
finances and and things that you worry
about when you're you know 50 60 70
years old I think that that's the kind
of thing that that there's a replacement
um by the younger generation and that
that that demographic is probably going
to they won't be going to your average
or your your mainstream news but they'll
be looking to places like YouTube uh as
they get more interested in in topics
that that affect them because I think
the young people don't really pay
attention a lot I think that it's a it's
a rare thing so and they don't have
cable I mean fewer people have cable
news I mean I don't remember the last
time I paid for cable and had cable at a
place where I live like